la hermana de fernando le prestó dinero
y él le pagó tiempo después fernando
gráfico la relación entre el tiempo
transcurrido en semanas desde el
préstamo y la cantidad de dinero que aún
le debía a su hermana qué característica
de la gráfica representa el tiempo que
le llevó a fernando pagar el préstamo
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
muy bien analicemos cada una de estas
opciones la primera es la pendiente la
pendiente nos dice cuál fue el cambio en
la dirección vertical para cierto cambio
en la dirección horizontal por ejemplo
si comenzamos aquí podemos ver que al
transcurrir una semana pasamos de la
semana 1 a la semana 2 el préstamo
disminuyó porque pasó de 15 pesos a 10
pesos
tenemos más 1 en las semanas del tiempo
y el préstamo disminuyó 5 pesos y lo
mismo sucede en la siguiente semana la
pendiente indica la tasa a la que
disminuye el préstamo y será constante
durante todo este periodo de tiempo es
lo que la hace una recta la pendiente
siempre es constante la pendiente nos
sirve para conocer la tasa a la que se
paga el préstamo pero no es la forma más
clara para saber cuánto tiempo le llevó
a fernando pagar el préstamo así que
descartamos esta opción la siguiente
opción es la intersección en x que se
refiere al lugar donde la gráfica intel
al eje horizontal que muchas veces se
indica como el eje x otra forma de
pensar en esto es que nos dice cuál es
el valor en x cuando el valor vertical o
el valor en y es igual a 0 y el eje
vertical es el dinero adeudado así que
nos dice cuánto tiempo ha transcurrido
hasta que fernando ya no debe dinero a
su hermana justamente esto es lo que nos
preguntan el tiempo que le llevó a
fernando pagar el préstamo la respuesta
a esto está en la intersección en x
después de cuatro semanas
fernando ya no debe dinero a su hermana
me gusta esta opción pero vamos a
revisar las otras la intersección en y
aquí es donde la gráfica interpreta al
eje y esto nos dice lo que sucede cuando
el tiempo es igual a cero cuando el
tiempo es cero o la variable horizontal
es cero
vemos que fernando debe 20 pesos por lo
que esto no nos dice cuánto tiempo le
tomó a él pagar el dinero sino que sirve
para saber cuánto dinero debía
inicialmente descartamos esta opción y
como ya elegimos una opción descartamos
esta de ninguna de las anteriores